Silva has come to veluka Guild's from  around the world and another time have  flown in to compete the rulership over  veluka the jewel of the Federation here  you see that later staking claims  throughout the city by putting up  towards looks like another guild is  moving in they've sent forces to knock  down that tower and clean veluka flower  may the best deal with huge creatures  without your worst nightmares must have  heard the fighting they're heading  straight to the battlefield now the  Guild's have a tough decision and  together and bankers the faux fur grey  rewards or keep fighting among  themselves looks like some of those  weaker Gil's left that tower is  undefended  which will be last killed left standing  which guild will rule veluka it could be  yours